you
I was disappointed in the toxin
Copenhagen I think there was a lot of
expectations maybe expectations were
greater than they should have been this
is not an area of expertise of mine how
things get negotiated in the political
domain on a global basis so whatever
views I have would be those of you know
a reasonably well informed citizen and
somewhat casual observer but I can't say
that in looking at the tape at Peter and
there's always the danger that since I
just wrote a book on integrated
reporting on the hammer and everything
looks like a nail but as I watched his
tape and he made a compelling argument
for why simply jumping to biofuels was
not a logical conclusion because he
discussed the difference between oil and
biofuels in terms of the amount of water
that needs to be used and for biofuels
the plant matter that could be food and
used in another way I was saying to
myself if if we were thinking about
climate change just climate change in a
more integrated way and we weren't just
focused on carbon but if we were
thinking carbon we were thinking water
we were thinking food we were thinking
about what the relationships are with
the trade-offs are because there's tough
choices that have to be made it's easy
to say we can optimize across every
environmental dimension while we're
optimizing you know across financial
performance and quality of life but
that's not the world we live in I think
in some cases we can do better on all
counts in other cases tough choices have
to be made and what what Peter's video
clip said to me was if we were taking a
more integrated view and we were looking
at data and analyzing data in a more
integrated way I think we could be
making much better decisions